there's a confrontational heir to your
personality which i've always loved
you like things to be difficult you like
to
get into it with people you don't want
it to be a smooth ride
and i sympathize because i i think there
is something of an irish quality where
we we expect it to be difficult we want
it to be difficult and we're
uncomfortable if it's easy
for a long time you were going on
twitter and you were
just trying to irritate people and start
fights
isn't that true well i mean i'm still
try but everybody knows my game
but yeah when i started out i i just
noticed i put some ironic tweet out
there like you know
to me the best uh the best beatles song
is i got my mind set on you
it's not even a beatles song it's a
george harrison solo song
from the 80s a lot of people a lot of
people pointed that out
too
well for a while i was just doing music
trolls where i was like
you know i like real punk you know like
i'm i'm not into this new punk i'm into
like real punk like
ramones and avril lavigne
and people would get so mad you just
kind of that kind of thing you know
yeah yeah you even get you get mad at
people uh
if someone says they don't like the
beatles that pisses you off
well that bugs me i mean talk about
trolling
everybody that doesn't like the beatles
they're just
dying for you to go what they think
they're to blow your mind
that's what bugs me they're not if they
don't not like the beatles they just
want to blow your mind with their you
know iconoclastic
person the best thing to do with
somebody says they don't like the
beatles just go okay
that'll ruin their whole day
[Laughter]
so that okay yeah i get it i get it